All six VLR designs have been revealed, including myself.
It's not traditional for an agency to have six talents for one generation,
but the development team said, and I quote,
there should be one design you naturally gravitate towards.
So, who do you like the most?
Is it Icy?
The insomniac polar bear with scars?
Any the Hexmaniac of the group and the only one of us with a tattoo?
Strony the hypnotizing cuttlefish that's also siren, but can't sing.
Mercy the love-struck yonder, but can't seem to ever love right.
She be the bunny-milk who likes to work hard, but play harder.
And last but certainly not least,
Ezra the goat goddess with milkers bigger than your b**ch.